Sabrina Ali bernali lässt sich nicht
anmerken dass sie schon eine Schicht im
Krankenhaus hinter sich hat
Entschuldigung
zu Hause die 38-Jährige will sich auch
nachts für ihre Patienten Zeit nehmen
Raphael hat Fieber seine Mutter macht
sich Sorgen und hat den Notarzt gerufen
Paracetamol alle sechs Stunden und wenn
das Fieber nach drei Tagen nicht weg ist
dann melden sie sich wieder
danke auf Wiedersehen
wir begleiten die Notärztin bei ihrer
Nachtschicht durch Paris wollen Sabrinas
Arbeitsalltag kennenlernen um zu
verstehen warum sie in ihrer knappen
Freizeit wie tausende andere Franzosen
auf die Straße geht um gegen die
Rentenreform zu protestieren
es bleibt jetzt nur noch die Gewalt für
die Menschen die nicht mehr können ich
weiß nicht wie die Leute ihr Lieben
finanzieren sollen ich bin teilweise bei
Patienten zu Hause in Wohnungen nicht
mehr als 20 Quadratmeter groß da sitze
ich auf dem Boden weil es keinen Platz
gibt das sind Leute die 800 Euro im
Monat verdienen und nicht mehr ihr Essen
bezahlen können und macron weiß einfach
nicht wie die Menschen lieben und dann
sagt er uns ja ihr müsst ein bisschen
länger arbeiten
zum nächsten Einsatz muss es schneller
gehen der Patient hat Atemnot also
Interview auf dem Weg sie selbst sei
verhältnismäßig privilegiert erzählt uns
Sabrina der Mutter von zwei kleinen
Kindern geht es bei ihrem Kampf gegen
die Rentenreform um Gerechtigkeit und
Demokratie
soll einfach sagen ich ziehe meine
Reform zurück voila das ist alles was
wir verlangen das wars
zumindest um die Wut der Menschen zu
beruhigen weil die Leute sind jetzt zu
aufgebracht und danach kann man ein
faires demokratisches Vertrauen wieder
herstellen
Demokratie die Nächte in Paris sie sehen
auch so aus im Moment wenn nicht hören
will muss fühlen ist das Motto der
Proteste die werden mit jeder Nacht
radikaler gewaltvoller seitdem Präsident
macrons Regierung die umstrittene
Rentenreform ohne Abstimmung durchs
Parlament geboxt hat es brennt auf
Frankreich Straßen
[Musik]
ja es gibt Feuer aber die hat die
Regierung gelegt nicht die Menschen
bis jetzt waren wir freundlich aber
jetzt müssen die Proteste ein bisschen
härter werden weil sonst will macron ja
nicht hören
seit Monaten wird Frankreich weit
demonstriert und gestreikt es waren
friedliche Proteste von den
Gewerkschaften organisiert die
Forderungen sind immer die gleichen wir
wollen wir können nicht länger arbeiten
auch weil die frühe Rente seit den 80er
Jahren als hart erkämpfte soziale
Errungenschaft in Frankreich gilt mit
viel Symbolkraft
Sabrina ali benali ist von Anfang an
mitmarschiert mit Kind und Partner haben
wir sie schon einmal im Februar bei
einer samstagsdemonstration in Paris
getroffen
ist wieder unser Papa noch unser
Schuldirektor er steht im Dienst der
Franzosen das macht uns wütend weil er
nicht über unser Leben entscheiden darf
er entscheidet und hält sich
währenddessen öffentlich auffällig
bedeckt über Monate bekommt das Volk
Präsident macron nur bei sehr wenigen
ausgewählten Auftritten zu Gesicht bei
der Landwirtschaftsmesse Ende Februar
etwa oder auf dem Großmarkt außerhalb
von Paris ein Präsident der Arbeitern
Hände schüttelt und versucht zu erklären
warum Frankreich unbedingt eine
Rentenreform braucht
wenn wir nicht länger arbeiten was
bleiben für Möglichkeiten denen die
Arbeiten mehr Geld wegnehmen die haben
eh schon nicht viel sie wollen mehr
verdienen und die bestehenden Renten
kürzen bei Rentnern die jetzt schon
nicht viel haben da gibt es nichts zu
kürzen also müssen wir länger arbeiten
sein Plan das Renten Eintrittsalter
schrittweise vom 62 auf 64 Jahre erhöhen
die Rentenreform ist macrons großes
amtsvorhaben nach wochenlang
Massenprotesten im Winter
2019/2020 musste er sie schon einmal
zurückziehen jetzt beim zweiten Anlauf
sollte das nicht passieren es folgte
eine verkürzte debattenzeit mit
beschleunigten Verfahren und weil eine
Mehrheit in der Nationalversammlung
nicht sicher schien entschied die
Regierung vergangene Woche das Gesetz
gar nicht erst abstimmen zu lassen
die Opposition stimmt die Nationalhymne
an sieht die Demokratie in Gefahr doch
das Verfahren ist rechtmäßig darauf
beruft sich der französische
Staatspräsident und auch wenn nur knapp
gescheitertes Misstrauensvotum lässt ihn
nicht abrücken
wird keine Kehrtwende bei seiner Reform
machen weil sie von seinem Beratern als
Sieg angesehen wird und er sie als Sieg
ausgibt das Hauptproblem ist nicht mehr
die Rentenreform es geht um die
Demokratie das ist der Elefant im Raum
sind wir noch in einer Demokratie können
wir noch kollektiv entscheiden oder ist
dies ein System in dem nur Einer für
alle anderen und sogar gegen alle
anderen entscheidet
Präsident gegen Volk am Mittag äußert
der sich in einem Fernsehinterview
versucht zu beschwichtigen ohne
abzuweichen
denken sie mir macht diese Reform Spass
nein glauben Sie ich hätte dasselbe tun
können wie viele andere vor mir und den
Staub unter den Teppich kehren können ja
vielleicht in Wirklichkeit bedauere ich
heute nur eines dass wir nicht in der
Lage waren über die Zwänge und vor allem
die Notwendigkeit dieser Reform zu
informieren
außerhalb der Mauern des elise-palasts
scheint das Ansehen des Präsidenten
währenddessen immer weiter zu sinken die
Proteste werden makabra und die
Rebellion gegen die Rentenreform nimmt
kein Ende